ماذا عن اخر التطورات التي سجلت في مناطق
شمال القطاع ومدينه
غزه في شمال القطاع خفت حده القصف الى
مستويات كبيره جدا لكن لا تزال لا يزال
القصف متواصل خاصه القصف المدفعي في
المناطق الشرقيه والمناطق الشماليه
الغربيه وهي اماكن تواجد قوات الاحتلال
لازالت قوات الاحتلال تقصف في المحيط هذه
الاماكن التي تتواجد بها لكن يطفو على
السطح كثير من القضايا الانسانيه التي
تعمقت وتاز وزادت في ظل ممارسات الاحتلال
واخر هذه الازمات هو فقدان الكثير من
الاهالي لابنائهم وعدم معرفه مصيرهم في ظل
اعتقال قوات الاحتلال لعشرات بل مئات من
الفلسطينيين دون معرفه مصير هذه
الاعتقالات بالاضافه الى ذلك اعتقال قوات
الاحتلال الكثير من الفتيات من منطقه ابو
اسكندر وحتى هذه اللحظه لا يعرف مصير هذه
الفتيات ولا مصير عائلات التي اعتقلت او
الشبان الذين اعتقلوا من هذه المنطقه
العائلات تناشد بشكل متكرر الهيئات
الدوليه ومنظمه الصليب الاحمر
ومنظمه والمنظمات الاخرى التي هي تعنى
بهذه القضايا ان تكشف عن مصير ابنائها
وتساعدهم في الكشف عن مصير ابنائهم
بالاضافه الى ذلك ال القضايا الانسانيه
التي تتعلق في البرد القارس في هذه
المنطقه الان يشتد البرد ونحن الان في
منتصف البرد الشديد في مدينه غزه الكثير
من العائلات هي فاقده للغطاء في ظل نزو
وقصف مبانيها وقصف بيوتها دون الخروج من
هذه البيوت باي ملبس او اي غطاء يوى به
تتاوه به هذه العائلات من هذا البرد
الشديد الذي تتعرض له في منتصف هذا الشهر
يكون هو الاشد بروده على مدينه غزه ولا
تستطيع العائلات حتى او لا ي لا يوجد لا
تدخل مع المساعدات حتى هذه اللحظه الاغطيه
اللازمه لهذه العائلات فهناك مناشدات
لادخال المساعدات وخاصه المساعدات التي
تختص بالاغطيه والالبسه التي تحمي من هذا
البرد القارص والمتواصل على مدينه غزه